hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen and another edition of
what I eat in a date youtuber review so
I've been reading all of your comments
and a lot of you guys have asked me to
review a carnivores diet and there's a
few of them the few names that I've seen
come up often but I'm gonna work my way
through and start with this guy his
name's sub-3 rich I don't know how to
say his name so I'm just gonna call him
gotough goatee goat man I don't know
cue the t-swift that's all I know second
of all I want you guys all to know how
much I love you because it was like
painful for me to watch these videos for
a lot of reasons many of which I don't
have time to like get into detail on
during this video but things like the
fact that he thinks the earth is flat
but he seems like he's anti-semitic and
also he has another video called serial
killers are the real heroes organ
harvesting and when asked if he's
suggesting that we kill an e people his
response was yes yeah and YouTube
screened and pulled down my video
YouTube we got to do better at this we
got to take this down but anyway I am
here to talk food not politics so I want
to get into analyzing his diet before we
get started a big big big warning
especially to all of my vegan
what you are about to see probably will
offend you because quite honestly it
offends the FATA me too so let's do this
that's enough of that I would say um I
just want to say that I'm trying really
hard to be professional and kind with
this review but I'm struggling like
immensely to watch this first scene
basically what we're seeing is a hooded
man hunched over in a dark apartment
shoving raw meat and butter into his
face fine fine well let's talk about
that liver that he's consuming right
there so don't get me wrong
liver is probably one of the most
nutritious organs that you could eat
however like most things too much of a
good thing can be a bad thing
like a really bad thing and in the case
of liver we're talking about vitamin
toxicity vitamin A toxicity to be
specific and yes that's a real thing
so one 3.5 ounce of beef liver contains
about six times the recommended amount
of vitamin A should be getting per day
and vitamin A toxicity can lead to
vision problems bone pain and risk of
fractures it also has more than your
recommended cholesterol for the day and
while new research does not suggest that
cholesterol is necessarily the cause of
heart disease I would still say that you
want to go easy on the portion sizes and
yes totally fine in moderation but in
combination with everything else going
on in this guy's diet including that
stick of butter he's consuming I would
say it's overkill all right let's get to
his next meal
there's chunks in it there's chunks in
it so the massive chunk of blood is like
a lot for me right now and I watch a lot
of true crime so you think I was down
with all the creepy but no still wanna
vom watching that I can't believe I'm
gonna say this but I would like I'm
longing for the the raw vegans token
green juice right now but in any case
let's talk about blood so eating
coagulated blood is actually quite
common in some places at the world so
I'm gonna try really hard not to yak
somebody's young however generally it's
mixed with salt and then either come to
cubes or aspects with other meats and
stuff into casings to make sausages with
blood sausage I've had it before I don't
love it but like I don't hate it now I'm
sure a lot of you can imagine that
people who eat or drink blood claim that
it's a rich source of heme iron and can
help prevent anemia now I'm not gonna
argue with that of course blood is a
great source of iron but as you can see
and when you do from all of the animal
products this guy is eating in his day
iron is really not a nutrient of concern
for him is there such thing as too much
iron yes theoretically definitely an
iron overload can cause things like
arthritis cancer heart problems liver
problems diabetes even but generally we
see this from an excess of iron
supplements or if you have an absorption
disorder could it happen from food
possibly especially if this guy's is
prone to iron overload however the body
really tightly regulates how much iron
is absorbed based on how much or how
little is given being our concern that I
have is around food safety so the who or
the World Health Organization have found
a few cases of bird flus that they
specifically linked to people who
consumed raw blood based dishes so
definitely not something that I would
want to contract
Oh God guys look at an office mustache
okay that's enough I know it's enough we
we're all cringing here yeah nothing
like cracking into a sketchy bag of
butter
this is soured butter to be exact so
basically soured cultured butter is made
kind of like sour cream or yogurt by
taking better and of course showering it
with some kind of bacterial culture
sounds like something I would find at
some kind of like experimental Michelin
star restaurant served with some
fancy-ass brioche so I'm down with the
concept but to just like eat chunks of
it like that is like really making my
mouth water and not in like a good
mouth-watering way like when your mouth
waters right before you're going to yak
so that's happening that's fun right now
also like for the love of all that is
holy can this somebody just get this guy
a napkin it's getting like really really
grotesque savage would be a better name
for this guy it's I'm over Asst
what correcting yeah oh yeah what kind
of conversation is whose enema is this I
like what a classic response my enema
I'm just holding it for a friend
what the [ __ ] all right I can take an
oyster we all love a good moisturizer
anyone so I am so happy to be seeing
that happening right now I can actually
like watch through this this sequence
and they're a great source of low fat
protein to really balance out like stick
of butter that he just ate so I'm gonna
give him the stamp of approval for that
okay so obviously the oysters were just
not cutting it we got an snack
no he's like eating like a burrito in
the back of a cab like that is one way
to kill your uber rating right there but
also can we talk about how effortlessly
he is chewing through that raw duck
breast that raw fat like what the [ __ ]
honestly the thought of eating through
that much ruff that reminds me of what
it'd be like to eat through like a cheap
foam sold flip-flop no also food safety
again this guy just like pull out a raw
piece of meat out of his backpack for a
quick snack attack he's asking for
salmonella poisoning alright so we're
back at home for another snack two cups
of cod cheese it looks like
I love cottage cheese I really do it's a
great high-protein snack but I'm not
sure I could consume two cups in one go
all by itself also are like spoons and
no go on this diet because like does he
have to be that Savage this is probably
not the kind of guy you want to bring to
like a fancy dinner party or your
parents house for a lot of reasons yeah
he also seems to surround himself with a
lot of like-minded people like his
friend milk jar that's all and then
later I'm going to have the rest of my
testicle glad you're eating your own
house testicle bud I don't know which
these two guys are worse but it clearly
Birds of avian flu feather flock
together is what I'm gonna say about
that but you know this guy's talking
about his cause cheese and his steak and
his honey and his eggs and his bull
testicle that he's got to come back to
because apparently that's a delicacy
that you gotta savor like what is this
guy on Survivor is he trying to win a
prize what kind of day of eating is this
as a result and the program it's protein
hmm I really do think that art is
subjective but considering there's a a
swastika on this person's forehead
I will openly say that this is clearly
anti-semitic and just plain ugly
honestly I was trying to have like an
open heart and open mind with this guy
and his diet and everything he stands
for but quite frankly this is really
offending me sounds so first of all
they're like double yolk eggs it's like
he can't just have normal eggs he needs
the extra fat because he hasn't had
enough of that today but the weird thing
if you just put the shells in his pocket
like it's so strange this man is so
strange in some of his diet Aryan eating
behaviors it's just bizarre to me but
now I want to break it down and talk
about the macros cuz there is a lot
going on here
so four total calories we're looking at
about 2,300 and in terms of the macros
it's about 67% fat 7% carbs and 26%
protein so not surprisingly his
macronutrient distribution is definitely
a little out of whack and unbalanced
he's consuming dangerously high levels
of saturated fats from foods like the
really fatty duck breast the egg yolks
and a ton of butter he's consuming very
low amounts of carbohydrates less than
40 grants in a day and his protein
levels are within range and he's
consuming fairly good sources from
things like eggs the deliver and the
cottage cheese as well but macros tell a
very small part of the whole story so
let's talk about what's lacking in his
diet honestly a heck of a lot if his
diet looks like this every day
this guy is likely missing out on a lot
of vitamins and
Neuros sure he's probably not deficient
in iron or B vitamins but without any
fruits or vegetables or whole grains
he's probably missing out on a ton of
important fiber and of course a lot of
the micronutrients as well so let's talk
about those so first of all I'd be
particularly worried about a lot of the
water soluble vitamins and antioxidants
like vitamin C cuz I'm not seeing any
fruits and vegetables going in right
here also he's potentially at risk of
vitamin A toxicity and copper toxicity
if he's consuming a lot of organ meats
like liver on the daily I also want to
pull up his blood test results which let
me tell you I think it's really weird
that he posted online but anyways let's
take a look so based on these results
he's within range for the few markers he
chose to test and disclose however there
are other really important numbers I
would like to see to get a better view
or or take on his overall health things
like calcium potassium sodium magnesium
and of course the most important
cholesterol he mentioned in his blood
test video that we would have to donate
50 euros in order to see his LDL
cholesterol numbers which i think is
kind of like super sketchy as but I
would also really like to see his urea
nitrogen levels so that I could assess
his kidney function considering he's
consuming so much animal protein also we
can only hope that this guy is adding
some kind of multivitamin to his diet
routine but like with most youtubers we
don't hear anything about that
now let's discuss the elephant in the
room is eating raw meat safe
not really so compared with raw fish raw
meat specifically has types of bacteria
in it that can cause food poisoning
specifically things like e.coli now even
in places like Japan which are known for
serving up like liver sashimi and other
raw meat delicacies the Japanese
Ministry of Health Labor and Welfare to
man that people stopped serving up raw
liver raw beef liver because of so many
cases deadly cases of food poisoning now
of course there are ways to reduce your
exposure and your risk of food poisoning
things like safe handling practices
using really good quality me
and also storage and refrigeration
however there are a lot of moving parts
before that food ends up on your plate
the other question I'm probably gonna
get asked is is raw meat more nutritious
no I know raw carnivores will share
sensationalized
anecdotes about how much healthier is to
eat raw however there's no scientific
evidence that there's any benefits to a
raw meat diet what we do know is that
the more processed a meat product is the
higher the risk of cardiovascular
disease and certain cancers however
highly processed foods are not the same
thing as cooked foods these are two
different concepts so let's talk more
about the cooked versus uncooked thing
here because this guy seems to think
that cooking ruins two nutritional
properties of food and I want to unpack
that a little bit so we cook meat some
of the enzymes are deactivated at a
certain temperature and raw food
advocates claim that this can lead to
enzyme deficiency where this does not
actually make that much sense because
our body has its own enzymes that we use
to digest food and we don't rely on the
enzymes in food to digest it and do it
for us
scientists have chimed in on this and
agree that there's no evidence to
suggest that raw enzymes contribute to
better health or that cooked enzymes
have some kind of negative impact on our
health what I can say is that there are
some nutrients that are depleted by
cooking things like vitamin C or B
vitamins can get leached into the water
and for that reason we recommend fast
cooking methods things like steaming or
stir frying to get the biggest nutrient
bang for your buck on the flip side
there are vegetables and nutrients that
are actually enhanced by cooking so
things like carrots tomatoes peppers
spinach all of these have enhanced
antioxidants when they're cooked versus
when they're raw when it comes
specifically to raw meat Harvard
researchers actually found that cooked
meat actually supplies more energy to
the body than raw meat so move along raw
carnivores how long should anybody
actually be eating this much animal
product well researched over the years
has shown that increasing the amount of
plant-based foods in your diet and
reducing the amount of animal priced in
your diet can help reduce the risk of
cardiovascular disease diabetes and all
cause mortality so in short I would say
No now next I want to talk about
digestion not to get any more graphic
than we already have in this video but I
would not want to be in the same house
as this guy when he takes a dump
cooking tends to make food a lot easier
on our digestive system because it means
it's easier to chew which in turn makes
it easier to digest and that will cut
back on gas and bloating this guy also
has legit no fiber in his diet so I can
only imagine how many magazines he
probably goes through as bathroom
reading material every single day
finally I want to talk about this guy's
philosophy so in the past we've reviewed
other vegan youtubers what ate in a daze
and these youtubers tend to be really
aggressive in their own food
philosophies and shame other people who
don't follow along as hardcore as them
but what about people like godus do we
want to encourage other people to eat
like this especially with what we know
about the environment eating this way
would require you to eat a ton of meat
every single day which not only has
health implications and is very
expensive but also can be super damaging
to our environment the point is going to
distri monde
either end of the spectrum is
devastating in its own way
finding more balanced approach to eating
is a really important way to ensure that
you're getting all the nutrients you
need and also keeping mother nature
healthy and happy I also just want to
say that I really don't like this guy's
activity on YouTube he seems to have
made a life out of taunting vegans by
showing up a vegan events or restaurants
to eat raw meat and also is making a lot
of videos about vegans talking about how
they're malnourished like nobody
no we need vegans in this world to
balance out people like your meat
consumption it is a huge problem and you
don't be a dick about it
honestly I'm over this guy and I'm so
glad we're at the end of this video so I
don't have to talk about him or watch
his videos anymore so guys I hope you
enjoyed this video and my what I eat in
a day series if you did be sure to give
it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below if you've made it this far
watching what he has been eating I would
love to know other youtubers who you
want me to review subscribe to the
channel and
we'll see you next time on Abby's
kitchen bye